we start today with stunning hypocrisy
uh Republican Congressman James Comer
was asked by CNN's Jake Tapper okay
you're investigating or you want to
investigate Joe Biden's handling of
classified documents after 15 or 20
documents were found in Biden's
possession which his lawyers immediately
contacted the National Archives and
turned over fine you want to investigate
that but then you must also want to
investigate Donald Trump right I mean
Trump had at least hundreds of documents
and Trump deliberately took them and
Trump used lawyers to try to avoid
giving them back rather than immediately
turning them over clearly if you're
investigating Biden you must also want
to investigate Trump and James Comer
can't explain why he's investigating Joe
Biden and not Donald Trump this is
brazen hypocrisy obvious partisanship a
humiliating double standard but
it's Republican politics in 2023 and it
has been for a while let's take a look
and Jake Tapper visibly exasperated
because what James Comer is saying makes
no sense whatsoever let's go there
because you're talking about the Trump
documents former president Trump is
under an investigation for his own
classified documents they're about 20 in
the case of Biden from Trump they're
about there are more than 300 classified
doctors in Mar-A-Lago a big difference
here uh just on the facts Trump did not
fully comply with the subpoena his
lawyers falsely told investigators that
they turned everything in true um take a
listen to what you told CNN about this
situation last November this gets good
I don't know much about that that's not
something that we've requested
information just to see what was going
on because I don't know what documents
were at Laura Largo uh so you know by
the way Mara Largo listen we went to
mar-a Largo and there were no documents
right well because that's not the place
something we're just waiting to see what
comes out on that but is it fair
that will not be a problem so what do
you say to viewers who don't understand
why President Biden's documents seem
like a big priority for you yeah but
president Trump who took hundreds more
documents did not comply with the
subpoena did not reach out to the
National Archives or the justice
department to say hey we found these
documents it's not a priority do you
only care about classified documents
being mishandled when Democrats do the
mishandling yes that's absolutely right
right Jake I'm a partisan hack
absolutely not but we still don't know
what type of documents president Trump
had that's one of the questions we've
asked National Archives just because Joe
Biden's lawyer said they turned over
five documents doesn't mean they just
turned over five documents they could
have turned over 500 documents I'm sorry
but I don't have a lot of confidence in
President Biden's personal lawyers at
the end of the day the National Archives
implied to us at former chairman
Maloney's request and told us that the
National Archives was working with the
Trump Administration during the
transition that's the last communication
we had with whether or not the archives
had worked if you are confused and
you're wondering where is the answer
about why we care more about the Biden
thing than the Trump thing with the
documents if you're searching in this
clip for that answer it's not there
that's why you're confused Trump on uh
removal of of all the documents from the
White House so we don't know exactly
what Trump has versus what Biden has
yeah and part of the reason they don't
know if they is they've said the Trump
aspect of this just isn't a priority
they're not trying to find out end of
the day my biggest concern isn't to
classify documents to be honest with you
my concern is how there's such a
discrepancy in how former president
Trump was treated by raiding Mar-A-Lago
by getting the security cameras by
taking pictures of documents on the on
the phone this is a circular I hope that
many of you recognize this is completely
circular he says listen I don't care so
much about the difference in the
documents I care about the difference in
how they were treated but of course to
understand the difference in how they've
been treated so far you have to
understand the difference between the
documents you have to understand the
difference between the number of
documents you have to understand that
Trump said take these documents to my
house whereas with Joe Biden everything
we know is that we're talking about
somewhere between one and two dozen
documents that Joe Biden didn't say keep
these put these in a box and put them
next to my Corvette this clearly was an
oversight which was immediately
turned over to the National articles if
you don't understand that then you
wouldn't understand the difference in
the treatment but that's exactly what
James Comer wants by going through
melania's closet yeah okay so that's uh
a complete inability or unwillingness to
explain what the difference is and James
Comer doesn't have any answers because
the answer is actually the simplest one
he's a partisan hack and he only cares
about the Biden documents because
Biden's a Democrat and comer is a
republican now Jake Tapper tried again
on this and said okay why are you asking
for the visitor logs for the Biden White
House for Joe Biden rather but not for
Mar-A-Lago or Mara Largo as Comer said
um and it's a the answer will will just
whatever the opposite is of a light bulb
going off that's what it is I I get that
but there's a big difference in how
President Biden and his team sorry this
is the wrong clip okay here nope that's
the okay I don't have the clip all right
well that's too bad that went that went
bad anyway uh I don't know where the
clip went and I apologize that the clip
has disappeared the question from Tapper
was why are you asking for the visitor
logs for Biden and not for Mar-A-Lago
and James Comer said well we're in the
middle of a Biden family influence
peddling investigation which is of
course an investigation that we knew
they would do but is a complete
distraction from actual things taking
place in the real world so even
Republicans aren't able to explain
why the Biden documents are a big deal
but the Trump documents are not we are
left to speculate my speculation takes
me to well it's because Trump's a
Republican and these hacks are also
Republicans Donald Trump was asked
finally about Ron DeSantis possibly
running against him and more generally
about Ron DeSantis Trump's answer is
stunning and insane and it is like that
of a mafia dawn of sorts Trump appeared
on the water cooler with David Brody of
course Trump not appearing in visual
form as he often is literally phoning
these in lately Trump asks about
DeSantis here is his insane answer I got
him elected pure it simple he would have
never if I if I said I wasn't going to
endorse you
and I was plus you know there was no
reason to go wild about the doors again
he was very nice in the sense of the
Mueller hugs
but just that is that is a bunch of
spaghetti thrown at the wall but it's it
just none it's four different things but
the most important there is
DeSantis won by 19 and Trump barely
mentioned the guy now Trump says well I
endorsed him but I didn't go crazy with
the endorsement Trump specifically
excluded DeSantis from his final rally
in Florida choosing to campaign only for
Marco Rubio and not Ron DeSantis
DeSantis won by 19 even though the
polling had him only Plus 11.
desantis's win is proof that Trump's
endorsement is worth a lot less than
Trump thinks not a lot more and now
Trump is getting all mixed up because he
knows what is potentially coming in 2024
between him and Ron DeSantis you know he
was one of about a hundred congressmen
who had fought for me and so you know I
felt I felt I might as well enjoy so
because I didn't know Adam brought them
but uh he was a three he was ready to
drop out of the race it was all done
Adam Putnam had that that nomination
locked up you know the Republican
nomination
he had it locked up it was done and when
I uh as Adam Putnam said to me when I
met him a year later I didn't know him
at all but I saw him he said it was like
a nuclear bomb went off a nuclear weapon
went off when you endorsement the race
was over he said he didn't even spend
his money there was no way he could have
beaten them after I endorsed him so you
know now I hear you might want to run
against me so we'll handle that the way
I handle things we will handle that the
way I handle things by which Trump means
character assassination
Petty nicknames name calling maybe even
attacking the physical appearance of
desantis's wife as he did to Ted Cruz
that's what Trump means by we'll handle
it the way I handle things and this
could really be Trump's undoing or it
could be desantis's undoing remember we
don't know it's not obvious that
DeSantis can actually handle a national
campaign against Donald Trump this
interview was Bonkers Trump then moved
on to saying that he is fighting the
Deep State Trump is still fully on this
conspiracy stuff saying he's he's got
the Deep State against him folks this is
a former president this is equivalent to
saying it's the Illuminati who tried to
end his candidacy and and you know I'm
beating the Deep state I'm fighting the
Deep State and winning you are and you
can't just be a real I think I am a very
nice person but if you're only going to
win we have to be tough and we have to
fight back right and again I was under
siege and I explained that to people who
soon as I explain it they always agree
basically you have to fight back and
when you fight back you know I want to
fight to win I want to win for the
country I want to win for the people and
you know I could see it kellyanne saying
well he wasn't very nice but I don't
want to be nice these are people that
are thugs they have very subject and
very bad people and if I fight back I
it's you don't sound as nice as you
should but Trump's the victim guys the
Deep state is against him everyone's
against him he's just fighting for
what's his and everybody calls him mean
what a victim this guy is Trump then
weighed in on the border and as is often
the case made something up whole cloth
that is untrue see if you can spot it
here like this this Potter is a disgrace
and I don't know if you know they're
letting in prisoners but they're letting
in all their people from mental
institutions many countries yeah letting
them in from that they're emptying out
their mental institutions let me into
the United States they are emptying out
their mental institutions into the
United States this would be on a
Jeopardy category called things that are
not happening and this would be the
Daily Double
um that is of course not happening and
it's not enough to say they're emptying
out their prisons into the country which
is what Trump used to say you always
have to become more hyperbolic so now
it's they're emptying out their mental
institutions Trump lastly then of course
talking about January 6th and um says
that he did absolutely nothing wrong
when it comes to January 6. what about
January 6. do you think Merrick Garland
is going to indict you regarding January
6 and what would be the Fallout if he
decided to do that right well I can't
imagine because I did absolutely nothing
wrong the speech it was peacefully and
patriotically which they never talked
about right all of the other things that
have come out we've done absolutely
nothing wrong
we I protest to this day I protest that
election that election was a disaster
right and so what Trump is saying of
course is that the rioters were right to
be there because Trump really did win
and the protesters rioters and
insurrectionists knew it and so they
were right to be there this is as
dangerous as you can imagine for a guy
who lost incited a riot is on the verge
of being indicted and is now running
again and one other aspect of this
interview that we're going to look at
separately
the evangelicals are not only turning on
Trump trump is turning on the
evangelicals this is absolutely
tremendous
Donald Trump is fully turning on
evangelicals for his 2024 run as the
race seems to be collapsing for Trump we
never count him out we know what
happened in 2016. but Trump is in
trouble here early trouble and
evangelicals seem to be abandoning him
and he is now furious with the
evangelicals this is part of that
interview we looked at earlier where he
appeared on the water cooler with David
Brody appearing by phone Trump's new
thing he's on by phone not by video and
uh here he is talking about the
disloyalty of Evangelical leaders who
have the audacity not to endorse Trump
you were The Ultimate Fighter the
ultimate counter puncher for sure and
that makes me think of evangelicals why
they loved you uh twice in those
elections and you announced when you
announce your candidacy at least as it
stands now some of these prominent
Evangelical leaders who backed you last
time they're not yet willing to commit
like Robert Jefferson's not some others
it's seems like many of them are waiting
to see how the field takes shape before
backing anyone what is your message to
them
well I don't really care
oh my goodness antifa has gotten into
Trump's audio defensive side of this
loyalty it's great disloyalty of the
world of politics and that decided to
loyalty because nobody as you know and
you would know better than anybody
because you do such a great job nobody
has ever done more for right to life
than Donald Trump I put three Supreme
Court Justices who all voted and they
got something that they've been fighting
for for 64 years or many many years
right nobody thought they could win it
you know they they won uh Roe v Wade
they won they finally won and you know I
was a little disappointed because uh I
thought they could have fought much
harder during the election during the 22
election because you know they won and a
lot of them uh
didn't fight or weren't really around to
fight and it did energize
the Democrats so it's a sign of
disloyalty says Trump that these
Evangelical leaders won't come out and
support him now here's the reality it
never made sense for Evangelical
Republicans to support Donald Trump it
never made sense and so now use whatever
phrase you like the chickens are coming
home to roost what goes around comes
around the bill is come do whatever this
was a sort of Faustian pact all along
for the evangelicals they really didn't
like Hillary they sort of wanted Ted
Cruz and then that didn't work out and
Trump called Ted Cruz's wife ugly and
things didn't go well and ultimately
they had Trump or Hillary as their
choice
um and then it was Trump or Biden and
Biden's Catholic and a lot of
evangelicals don't like that either and
so they went with Trump overwhelmingly
but it never made sense look at Trump's
past Behavior look at Trump's past
statements the extramarital affairs uh
the profanity the um you know way that
he has talked about women in the past it
doesn't align with what the evangelicals
want us to believe other Christian
values now want us to believe is doing
some heavy lifting there because are
these really their values that's kind of
a different question Trump's policy by
the way Trump's policies on health care
and immigration aren't really very
Christian either based on what are more
uh
more enlightened understandings of what
those Christian views are
um and at the end of the day the
evangelicals now are saying to
themselves we might not have to go with
Trump let's not jump on the Trump train
early because maybe somebody else will
actually best Trump in the Republican
primary so the evangelicals seemingly
turning on Trump trump immediately
turning on the evangelicals because
remember anyone who doesn't immediately
wholeheartedly and unanimously support
Trump
is being disloyal a couple weeks ago it
was the Jews being disloyal to Trump now
it's the evangelicals that's the framing
that's the that's the black white
thinking that people like Trump
narcissists egomaniacs that is the
framing through which they interpret
others actions we're going to take a
very quick break make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show what a
program we have for you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right my friends let's take a tour
through the disaster porn that is the
George Santos Fiasco as many of you know
George Santos is the Republican
congressman who has lied about
everything he lied about his education
he lied about his employment history he
lied about being Jewish he lied about
being a volleyball star he lied about
when and how and how seriously he got
coveted and was hospitalized and tested
positive I don't know if any of those
things are even true at this point in
time and there are even more lies and
you know I tweeted about some of these
people thought I was kidding it's become
a meme to say Emmy Award winner George
Santos and people go yeah okay funny
Abby award he didn't really say that he
won an Emmy that I'm aware of and I
tweeted George Santos claimed that he
had two knee Replacements from being a
volleyball star and people thought it
was one of those jokes it's not he
really claimed this there is there is
now a lie upon lie George Santos falsely
he claimed he was a volleyball star at
Baroque College in New York
he now has been caught on video claiming
that he was such a star that it led to
him messing up his knees and needing two
knee Replacements it doesn't appear to
be true this was on the Sid and friends
in the morning program back in 2020
listen to this this is unbelievable
George Santos running against Tom swazi
in that third congressional district
coming up next Tuesday hey you know it's
funny George you go right to the heart
here of me Sid and Bernie at the very
end of your biography it says in his
spare time right George Anthony enjoys
volleyball and Tennis let me tell you
why that's funny you're on this show
Bernie's daughter Melanie it's funny
because we're all liars as well was a
star volleyball player in college and my
daughter Ava as we speak is working on a
tennis scholarship when she goes to
college so now it's not enough that
they're all volleyball Stars even though
George Santos was not George Santos is
such a star that now he says he had two
knee Replacements it's it's amazing so
the two sports that you seem to enjoy on
the weekends are the same two sports our
two daughters excellent I daughters you
know it's funny I actually went to
school on a volleyball scholarship
I did yeah
um when I was in Baruch we were the
number one volleyball did you graduate
from there yeah so did I I did so did I
oh that's a lie great school great
institution very beautiful but very good
very good professors who don't show
their bias which is which is very
interesting but that's a whole nother
conversation but it's funny that we went
to we went to to play against Harvard
Yale and we
slay them I spiked four home runs and
three touchdowns and then my knees
exploded
we were Champions across the entire
Northeast Corridor every school that
came up against us they were shaking at
the time and it's funny I was the
smallest guy in I'm six two we had on
our block is he six two I mean we that's
probably a lie right I don't know if he
just he lies we should fact check his
height on our on our on our block alone
door six seven six eight these guys were
jumping they were just stretching their
arms
we were we weren't Adam all of us could
have been playing basketball but we
chose volleyball because it was easier
it was a great time I look I sacrificed
both my knees and got very nice knee
replacement uh knee Replacements from
HSS playing volleyball that's how
serious I took the game guys I mean he
actually listen he had knee Replacements
they were just on other people's knees
he organized knee replacements for other
people give the guy a break he actually
had four knee Replacements on three
knees if you would believe it it's multi
just one of the young it's a record
actually for how young and the number of
knee Replacements he's had lying and
lying and lying this is a sick person
this is an illness but that doesn't mean
we excuse it right the fact that he
seems to have this inability to control
his lying doesn't mean we say so he
should get to stay in congress he should
resign the pressure is building and it
appears that he has even lied about his
name George Santos
Anthony devolder who am I talking about
well apparently it's the same guy many
of you last week when I said George
Santos slash Anthony devolda wrote to me
and said David what are you what are you
talking about I what do you what do you
mean by that people wrote in asking
about this in 2019 George Santos
introduced himself not as George Santos
but as Anthony devolder the founder of
United for Trump this was a walk away
LGBT event in New York City the idea
being it's for LGBT people to abandon
the Republican Party here's a familiar
looking and sounding guy who says my
name is Anthony De volder yeah we're the
hater oh you got to be here there so my
name is Anthony devolder um I'm a New
York City resident I've recently founded
a group called United for Trump so if
you guys want to follow that would be
awesome my questions directed for both
Blair and um Brandon well Brandon's an
idol to all of us thank you Anthony
DeVoe older what is that now if you look
at his Wikipedia page apparently his
full name is George Anthony devolder
Santos uh is that accurate I guess
probably this is not the first time that
this has come up there's actually some
amazing video during his 2020 campaign a
guy who introduced Santos devolder at
the Queens Village Republican Club was
actually confused and said
this guy I know this guy is Anthony
devolder I don't even understand what's
going on here Texas this is out this is
amazing folks another important speaker
another Congressional nominee of George
Santos George who we know is a friend
and he's known as Anthony the boulder to
me so I don't know where George Santos
came into the end thing but that's what
it says to you yeah he's a republican
candidate this guy's like I've been
handed a piece of paper that says this
guy is George Santos but I've known him
as Anthony devolder and indeed here is
another video in which he introduces
himself as Anthony divulder good evening
everybody my name is Anthony divulder um
I recently founded a movement called
United for Trump on Facebook and by the
way I have to tell you he founded a
movement this is typical of people who
have these delusions of grandeur I
founded a movement dude you made a
Facebook page okay that's what you did
you founded them it's a real movement
it's incredible it's like Reform Judaism
it's a just an unbelievable movement
that has taken the World by storm
um next thing would be that and I people
have written to me about this and I I
hope this doesn't come up next thing
will be that he says he's trans or
something like that let's hope it
doesn't get to that point what is his
real name apparently it's George Anthony
Santos De volder Anthony George de
volder Santo something along those lines
we may never really know
last thing on George Santos Anthony
divulder okay plea just indulge me and
then we will move on for the day
George Santos claims that he developed
carbon capture
carbon capture technology
I'm not kidding okay uh I jokingly
tweeted a couple weeks ago that um
George Santos actually developed a very
interesting Dental uh technique for
filling cavities that was not true I was
joking but George Santos genuinely says
that he played a role in developing
carbon capture technology
listen to this long story short
canceling them from the Swift system is
this very smart move but it's not enough
we need to do more and as far as oil we
can fix this bring back energy
Independence Keystone XL pipeline stop
creating limits for the permits already
out there allow our men and women who
are out there drilling responsibly with
carbon capture technology that I've
helped develop that fundraise for in my
career I've had a very extensive role in
in gas and oil in this country and I can
tell you we cause far less harm to the
environment than the occasional accident
accidents it happens yes that's why
they're accidents right in every
industry accidents happen a banker can
accidentally round up a cash register
and add a zero and that changes
everything the whole yeah
um this is the problem with lying once
you start habitually lying you have to
keep lying to support the lies and these
are pointless lies they are lies of
self-aggrandizement carbon capture
technology has been developed by many
individuals and companies and
organizations none of them
are George Santos or Anthony devolder or
whatever other names that he has used
it's you know Dr Klaus lachner a
physicist Dr David Keith an
environmental scientist Dr Julio
Friedman or Dr Alan Wright Rodney John
Alum Eric McFarland Jennifer Wilcox a
chemical engineer there are people who
really were involved in developing
carbon capture technology uh Dr DDA
husin
um
George Santos Anthony devolder is not
one of the people that helped develop
carbon capture technology and he is so
far in with the reflexive lies the
instantaneous lies that it's
questionable whether he is even able to
control it
still don't want him in Congress he
still should resign I am hopeful that he
will be pushed out he is hopeful that
everybody will forget about this and
move on we have to do what we can to
prevent that from happening if you're
curious of what devolder Santos looks
like in these clips and you're just
listening today uh follow us on
Instagram or Facebook or YouTube where
we have all of these clips in audio
visual format for your viewing
displeasure I think is what I would call
it
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show a trump
supporting failed Republican candidate
has been arrested for his involvement in
the shootings that took place at the
homes of multiple elected Democrats
this is the United States of America in
2023 the world looks on in horror the
Albuquerque Journal reports failed
Republican candidate arrested in
shootings targeting Democratic
politicians homes Albuquerque Police
yesterday arrested the man they say is
The Mastermind behind a recent string of
shootings targeting Democratic lawmakers
homes the suspect Solomon Pena is a
republican who unsuccessfully ran in
November made repeated claims the
election was rigged and appears to have
attended the January 6th riots in D.C
around 3 P.M APD SWAT team swarmed a
condo complex executed a search warrant
made announcements for Penna who they
said may be armed with a firearm to
surrender as drones flew overhead within
an hour officers arrested Penna who's
accused of paying four men to shoot at
the homes of two County Commissioners
and two state legislators investigators
also believe penno was present for at
least one of those shootings Penna ran
unsuccessfully in house district 14
claimed on social media heat should have
won where have we heard that before he
also visited three of the targeted
officials homes unannounced in November
he showed up and said it was a fraud the
election should not be certified APD
essentially discovered what we had all
feared and what we had suspected these
shootings were indeed politically
motivated said Albuquerque mayor Tim
Keller they were dangerous acts not only
to these individuals but fundamentally
also to democracy what a
Trump supporting Republican thinks he
won an election he lost and is willing
to use violence against political
opponents not a shock sadly just another
day in the United States of America
under this authoritarian wannabe
dictatorial Republican party that prays
at the altar of Donald Trump
um in the back story of this is
interesting and disturbing in early
January APD disclosed it was
investigating several shootings
targeting Democratic elected officials
homes around the city
they said Bernalillo County Commissioner
Adrian barboas Southeast Albuquerque
home had been struck by eight bullets on
December 4th and a week later on
December 11 more than 12 bullets hit
County Commissioner Debbie O'Malley's
North Valley home they just show up and
shoot at the home so you understand
what's Happening Here Right on January
3rd shots rang out at State Rep Linda
Lopez's home in Southwest Albuquerque
three bullets went through her
daughter's bedroom as the 10 year old
slept
after news of the investigation
circulated State Rep Javier Martinez
current nominee for house Speaker then
rep for district 11. inspected his home
and noticed it too had damage from
bullets he had heard gunfire outside on
December 8th and believes that's when
the shooting occurred
these people are disgusting and these
are the very people who are the opposite
of what they claim to be by the way this
is terrorism in my mind this is
absolutely terrorism because this is
meant to send a message not only to
these individuals whose homes were shot
but more broadly when you say oh
Democratic legislator homes are being
shot it is meant to scare people who are
Democrats vote for Democrats would
consider running as Democrats Etc this
is a form of terrorism we must all ask
the question
how could Hunter Biden's laptop have
prevented this oh no sorry no no that's
that's wrong I'm I uh I'm now too sucked
into Hunter Biden's laptop because of
Republicans we must all ask the question
if they claim to be for Law and Order
but they do this are they really for Law
and Order if they claim to be for
democracy but they want candidates who
lost to still get sworn into office are
they really for democracy and for
counting all of the legal votes and all
of those things the answers of course to
all of these questions are no they are
not
they claim to be for these things and
they actually are not it is Terrorism
they found the guy let's now hope they
really throw the book at him and
prosecute him to the absolute fullest
extent of the law the signal needs to be
sent this isn't acceptable the problem
is we have too many in this country who
believe it is acceptable when you do
polls and we looked at them maybe six
weeks ago and you ask Americans is it
acceptable to use violence to achieve
your political goals more people than
ever and many more Republicans than
Democrats now say it is indeed
Republicans are looking to phase out
electric vehicles
why on Earth would they do that because
they want to defend and support to the
death the oil and gas industry let's
look at a couple of reports Newsweek
reporting Republicans want to phase out
electric cars to protect fossil fuels in
late December Oregon officials approved
regulations that would ban the sale of
new gas-powered vehicles in the state by
2035. that's pretty interesting two
states away in Wyoming Republican
lawmakers are looking to go in a
different direction rights Newsweek
pushing legislation that would ban the
sale of all new electric vehicles in
what lawmakers are calling an effort to
preserve the state's fossil fuel
industry what
sponsored by Casper Republican senator
Jim Anderson with the support of other
Republicans the resolution proposes to
phase out the sale of all new electric
vehicles in the state by 2035 to help
maintain the fossil fuel jobs that
underpin the state's economy imagine I
have Contraband I went to another state
to get it what is it is it is it meth
what is it is it the abortion pill
no it's an electric vehicle huh that's
pretty bonkers the proliferation of
electric vehicles reads the resolution
at the expense of gas powered vehicles
will have a deleterious we'll have
deleterious impacts on Wyoming's
communities and will be detrimental to
Wyoming's economy and the ability for
the country to efficiently engage in
Commerce they're just going to say you
can't buy electric vehicles anymore not
new and Gadget reporting Wyoming wants
to phase out sales of new EVS by 2035.
it's a symbolic gesture aimed at States
like California California New York of
course are going in the direction of
saying after a certain date we're not
going to allow ice Vehicles internal
combustion engine vehicles to be sold so
a couple thoughts first of all this is
not exactly the free market now you
could say electric vehicles shouldn't be
subsidized you could say that you could
take that you could make that argument
and say listen
um I really want a free market so the
government shouldn't offer rebates or
tax credits on electric vehicles now if
that's your position you should also say
that the government shouldn't subsidize
oil and gas fossil fuels at all right if
your position is no subsidies let the
free market decide you've got to get rid
of all subsidies and tax credits that
that is certainly one position but it is
not a free market to say phase out
electric vehicles but continue
subsidizing oil and gas which is exactly
what they want to do now you can make
arguments about electric vehicles that I
think are perfectly Fair arguments to
make like for example the sourcing of
some of the materials required to make
batteries is a problem I'm with you it's
got to be figured out there is no doubt
I believe it's Cobalt the sourcing of
cobalt for Batteries is a problem we
have to figure out what do we do with
spent electric vehicle batteries that
question is being answered it's being
worked on it's going to be figured out
but you have to remember that there are
some systemic fundamental advantages to
electric vehicles over gas powered
vehicles that make this
I I would never say this is the end
point once electric vehicles are
predominant there will be some next
thing right 100 years two three five
hundred years this isn't the end but
when you compare electric to gas powered
gas-powered Vehicles typically have
what's called energy conversion
efficiency of 20 that means 20 of the
energy stored in the gasoline before you
burn it is actually used to power the
vehicle 20 that's very low electric
vehicles have an energy conversion
efficiency of 90 meaning that 90 of the
energy stored in the batteries is
actually used to power the vehicle to
power its systems to move the vehicle at
the base level
electric vehicles are way more efficient
at using energy and they produce fewer
emissions now then you get to the next
layer benefit electric vehicles don't
have a tailpipe they don't emit
pollutants and greenhouse gases at the
tailpipe gas-powered Vehicles as they
drive around
spew dangerous pollutants like carbon
monoxide nitrogen oxides particulate
matter also all sorts of stuff terrible
for human health terrible for the
environment electric vehicles don't do
that there's no tailpipe emissions they
don't directly pollute the air now of
course
where's the electricity coming from the
electricity may be polluting the air but
you can get off of that you can power
your electric vehicle with solar energy
with wind energy and so every time you
go up up up the chain you reduce the
emissions and the benefit of electric
vehicles over gas powered vehicles grows
now
we still have problems to solve
but these are fundamental realities and
these Republicans I mean listen even the
uh Legacy automobile manufacturers are
realizing the direction things are going
they're trying to roll out the EVS
slowly right they still want to get as
much money out of ice Vehicles as they
can but even GM and Ford and all these
companies realize the way things are
going but Republicans some retrograde
Republicans are saying no no no no we're
not going to do it it is absolutely
horrifying and they don't actually care
you know this is like saying we don't
believe that smoking is bad let's have
this movement to maintain smoking in
restaurants that we've seen
um
the companies that for 40 years have
known that uh the harvesting of fossil
fuels is bad for the environment and
they cover up or they pretend they don't
know about it whatever the case may be
it is not only immoral in the long term
I actually think it's bad business but
the state of Wyoming says let's phase it
out
um it will be laughed at eventually I
don't know if it'll be five years from
now 10 20 it will be seen as absolutely
absurd that states once we have the
technology we're building out the
charging Network that states we're still
saying hey let's protect the cars that
drive around burning fossil fuels
putting it into the atmosphere
furthering the negative impact of the
entire fossil fuel industry it will be
seen as insane uh when I don't know but
Wyoming wants to wants to lead the world
in that it's disgusting let's take a
quick break and we'll be back after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Arkansas is now proudly and defiantly
led by new governor Sarah Huckabee
Sanders the daughter of former Arkansas
Governor Mike Huckabee and she is
wasting no time my friends she has gone
right to the heart of the matter of what
is most creating a problem for the state
of Arkansas she is Banning critical race
theory in K-12 schools which is not
taught in Arkansas
in K-12 schools huh wait a second I'm
not sure here is Sarah Huckabee Sanders
on Fox News Sunday the day before
yesterday and she is asked about the
anti-critical race Theory meth uh
measure that she signed despite the fact
that it's not taught in schools and she
had an answer ready here is that answer
that's right and we talked during the
commercial about the fact that you're
now growing up in the house or your kids
will grow up in the house where you grew
up
this time around but it sounds like your
daughter's gonna grow up in this face
you did as well
um you hit the ground running this week
after inauguration a number of executive
orders
um some folks love them some folks do
not let's talk about your critics uh
reaction to some of these orders one of
them is called executive order to
prohibit indoctrination and critical
race theory in schools the House
minority leader there in Arkansas a
Democrat says this we can't support our
teachers if we alienate and insult them
with headline grabbing executive orders
she says CRT is not being taught in
Arkansas schools axio seems to back her
up they said reality check there's no
indication that the college level course
is taught in any Arkansas Public School
so if that's true why the executive
order right
small government it's incredibly
important that we do things to protect
the students in our state we have to
make sure that we are not indoctrinating
our kids and that these policies and
these ideas never see the light of day
now of course a smart question here
would be do you have evidence that they
are being indoctrinated by critical race
theory that question is not asked we
should never teach our kids to
racist and evil country in fact it
should be the exact opposite we know for
a fact that the Federal Department of
Education issued CRT guidance and
policies to every school district in the
country our job is to protect the
students and we're going to take steps
every single day to make sure we do
exactly that and that's the reason I
signed the executive order I'm proud of
the fact that we're taking those steps
and we're going to continue to do it
every single day that I'm in office can
teachers though still have the
uncomfortable conversations about the
sins of our past about the things this
country has gotten wrong
our teachers absolutely need to teach
our history but they shouldn't teach our
kids and our students ideas to hate this
country and of course they are not being
taught that we must protect our students
vulnerable children from things which
are not being taught to them and this is
actually a classic of the American right
wing it's a classic of reactionary
populism it's a classic of
authoritarianism you invent a problem
and then you solve it you put out the
fire that you started but in this case
it's a fake fire in in in reality
it could be taught though David it could
be taught oh but it is not now SM
there's there's sort of two uh big
aspects to this one is they claim to be
small government conservatives they are
now passing laws against things that
could happen at some point but aren't
happening right now principle we are for
limited government reality we are
passing laws against things that aren't
even taking place not actually limited
government this is why Sarah Huckabee
Sanders ran for government uh for for
governor
um to appear on Fox News to spout
right-wing talking points and to claim
to have solved problems that are only
problems in the minds of these very
right-wingers because Banning something
that is not being taught in school is a
classic example of grandstanding and it
is what Fox News is there for for these
Republicans we're going to deal with the
m Ms that are the wrong gender and we're
going to deal with CRT which isn't being
taught and you're going to call us
Heroes for doing it but I want to
mention something else
this is a huge disservice to Arkansas
schools and what do I mean by that look
at Arkansas's rankings when it comes to
education they are in the toilet I don't
know how many times they've been flushed
but they're in the toilet Arkansas is
44th in the country in high school
graduation rate Arkansas is 40th in the
country in overall educational quality
according to U.S news and World Report
and according to Niche it's 49th in the
country in terms of overall educational
quality Arkansas is 44th in the country
in terms of overall educational
performance Arkansas is 45th in the
country in terms of overall child
well-being which includes other factors
like poverty and and food at school and
all these different things Arkansas is
47th in the country in terms of fourth
grade reading proficiency is Banning CRT
which isn't being taught going to help
fourth graders know how to read Arkansas
48 8th and 8th grade math proficiency
and according to the U.S Census Bureau
Arkansas is 48th in the country in terms
of median household income which is
highly associated with educational
outcomes is Banning CRT going to raise
household income in Arkansas which will
improve educational outcomes for kids no
they are Banning CRT which isn't taught
there despite being close to dead last
in so many educational indicators this
is a massive disservice to the people of
Arkansas I hope they see it she never
should have been elected and
um I mean listen meanwhile you look at
how Connecticut and California and
Massachusetts and Illinois and other
states are doing in education they're
not Banning critical race Theory math
scores are up reading proficiencies up
budgets are much healthier you know it's
it's the same old story it really is and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is now at the
front at the Forefront of it I
unfortunately have to do this segment
there are dangerously delusional people
in my audience
and one of the sorts of segments that
brings it out
is when I report
facts not giving my opinion I give
plenty of opinions on this show I'll say
listen I'm against the death penalty
that's my opinion let me tell you why
and people will write in and they'll say
oh well you know I agree with you or I
disagree or whatever but we know we're
talking about opinion last week I
reported to you that the rate of
inflation was down I didn't say that we
have deflation that's different I said
the rate of inflation is down a healthy
economy expects a little bit of
inflation I've explained why the rate of
inflation is down it wasn't my opinion
these are the numbers and the numbers
have been measured more or less the same
way for decades and I want to give you
some examples of the responses I saw the
comments I saw on YouTube and you will
very quickly see that we have a tragedy
of critical thinking really lack of
critical thinking in this country Jeff
responded quoting me used car prices
have gone down LOL obviously someone
isn't in the used car market
remember this isn't me driving around
looking at used car prices we have
monthly data on this issue folks like
Jeff when the data set used car prices
are up agreed with it because it was
what they wanted to tell as a story
because Joe Biden's president and he's
driving up the prices of used cars even
though it started under Donald Trump
during the pandemic and now it's oh
you're not in the used car market so you
don't actually know what's going on with
used car prices
this is my opinion this is the data if
you went to one used car lot and saw an
expensive used car that doesn't mean
anything about what's going on
nationally okay next example from Tulsa
have you checked the math David pakman I
bet if you check it you will find that
it's off a lot
I don't know what that means
I am reporting to you the inflation data
we have done stories on what goes into
the inflation number
I'm not doing the math but it's not math
in the sense you think it is this is the
same inflation data that when inflation
was high folks like this pointed doing
that look here are the numbers look at
how high inflation is now that
inflation's coming down they're like oh
no the math is all wrong really what do
you know about the math I'm curious Mr
talks responded LOL I call BS I don't
see prices dropping and eggs are Sky
High eggs aren't cheap so nope now my
personal experience is also that eggs
are expensive right now that's true
uh you know I buy my uh pasture-raised
cage free
liberal hipster eggs and they're
expensive they absolutely are expensive
but I understand that my experience of
buying eggs is anecdotal and it doesn't
tell me what's going on with inflation
numbers nationally but Mr talks saw
expensive eggs so the numbers must be
fake Brian wrote in inflation is down
where nothing has gone down in price
where I live I miss the old David Pacman
who didn't always simp for the
establishment you might as well work for
CNN or MSNBC you know these comments are
fascinating when I report that gas
prices are up
during Joe Biden's presidency people
like Brian go it's Biden's fault it's
terrible what's going on no questioning
of the data when I report that inflation
is Down based on the same sources Brian
doesn't like the content so it must be
that I'm simping for the establishment I
report data data that has been measured
the same way for decades unemployment
stock market inflation these aren't
opinions folks Zippy wrote in I'm not
seeing it prices are high in
Philadelphia again
you don't understand the difference
between anecdotes
and data
I
how many times do I have to explain this
a Newman with a total what about ISM
where is the coverage on the classified
documents David well I'll tell you where
it isn't in my segment about inflation
the coverage of the classified documents
is in the segment about classified
documents
classic what about ISM and then lastly
Robert says he's this is a different
approach this is the God-fearing
approach
your narrative and lies are catching up
to you God's watching you Parkman
presented completely without comment
this is really scary
because we are here in a country where
the average person lacks a basic degree
of ability to think through a problem
wow the report after inflation being
really high is that inflation is lower I
saw that eggs were expensive is that a
logical way to contradict a report no
it's not but of course that's not the
type of thinking that we frequently see
we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P here's a caller who wants
me to rank the soy boys listen to this
happy New Years cat girl
uh I have a serious question for you and
you have to answer truthfully by the way
the nickname there was pack girl for
those that not Pac-Man
pack girl very very uh impressive
truthfully
who is the bigger soy boy of the three
okay is it you
pathan nail polish Piper okay or destiny
ah answer truthfully please okay thank
you who is the biggest soy boy
is it me all right this is me
is it Hassan [ __ ] who wears nail polish
says this caller does Hassan wear nail
polish I don't know don't care or is it
Stephen Kenneth
Destiny benel II a well-known
cuban-american streamer
um I think the biggest soy boy
is definitely
uh me I don't know
um this is the type of stuff that the
right is concerned with soy boy and
um various uh insults and for those who
don't know if I understand the soy boy
insult correctly it's a right-wing
insult that takes the idea that liberals
is it that liberals don't eat meat or
something or that they like tofu I'm not
even really sure and soy Becomes
emblematic of lack of strength meat is
strength soy is a cheap
uh [ __ ] alternative I think that that's
the whole idea of soy boy these people
have real problems that I I'm sure that
you can tell we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today Joe Biden recently
questioned why police always shoot with
deadly force we're going to talk about
that on the bonus show we also are
seeing more States push for ranked
Choice voting in 2023 we will review
what is ranked Choice voting what are
its advantages what are its
disadvantages is it possible that we
will get to more widespread ranked
Choice voting nationally very
interesting topic and lastly Republicans
are now justifying their latest attack
on Social Security saying listen people
want to work longer let's raise the
retirement age because at the end of the
day it's what people want people want to
be working longer is that true but more
importantly is that a valid reason to
justify raising the retirement age all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
and make money let's do it everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad that's right Alex let's go make
money on the bonus show you can sign up
at
joinpakman.com you will get instant and
I really do mean instant access to the
bonus show you will get the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
every day hours before we publish them
for everybody else just by virtue of
being a member and we are days away from
launching the member sound board I have
received so many requests from people to
make a soundboard for our members that
mimics my soundboard where I play the
clips
exactly
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines we have built it we
are populating it with the clips soon
members will have access to my
soundboard it's a beautiful and exciting
thing you can sign up at joinpakman.com
I will see you on today's bonus show or
otherwise right back here tomorrow